so in short the gene expression pattern
for example can be Associated or can be
integrated with the clinical data and
this can help us identify molecular
biomarkers for Diagnostics and for
therapeutic selection and new
discoveries include better understanding
of complex diseases at the subsular
level as well as it can help us in the
Target identification for novel drug
design it can also help us repurpose
existing drugs for different purposes
one of the very famous example is the
usage of Metformin drug which was
traditionally or which is still used for
used to treat diabetes is actually reap
getting repurposed to treat
clinical cancer data or repurpose to be
anti-cancer drug in certain conditions
based on the omics data analysis
so what this actually creates is
this creates a disconnect between for
example the data that that is obtained
from the lab technicians and clinicians
and the data that can be processed and
understood from the
biomedical research ecosystem based on
the data analysis method and data
analytics that we can perform uh using
bio bioinformatics this disconnect
actually breaks up the cycle of
innovation due to lack of data-driven
research skills among the otherwise very
effective biomedical Personnel that we
have in in dealing with increasing
demands and increasing uh changing in
the unpredictable landscape of the omics
data that is currently presented so to
fill this Gap what we need to do is
we need to develop a more
um for example
um
ecosystems that are prone to uh prone to
be decentralized and that are proved to
be data driven approach right and we
have been given a taste for this current
scenario
from thanks to the pandemic or not
thanks to the pandemic this has already
started to affect health care and a more
subtle trends of disease management and
Drug development are also been observed
right and these industries are most
affected as going decentralized for
laboratory is has been found very
difficult and and many several harsh
coveted protocols has to be taken to
enable working inside this laboratory
environment but on the contrary
data-driven approaches in large-scale
projects can be performed in a
decentralized
manner and this is key to the future of
clinical and biotechnical
biotechnological Innovation where we
have plenty of mixed data we have plenty
of clinical data and they are waiting to
be approached in a data science oriented
or a data science
approaches and in this program we will
ensure that you get a taste of how this
is done by taking data from different
sources and then we will perform
analysis on the server Associated high
performance Computing server the server
how about bio info server and then we
will show you how to make the
associations from the omics data to the
disease biology
based on our analysis of this data
so we will also learn
about basic and translational research
in for example oncology where the
patient derives cell lines or xenograft
models and clinical trials offer a rich
collection of data to to for example
help us treat cancer in patients and
help us give informative diagnosis at
the patient level
so
um
this as I uh mentioned has completely
changed and it has given us a
complimentary information
uh approach towards this is biology
where we have traditional biological
hypothesis based approach can help us
validate once we have identified
specific markers and specific
therapeutic responsive agents elements
that we can use in the traditional
approach to verify and traditional
approach to build very built extremely
targeted assay based methods to
understand
um different for example understand
personalized and precision medicines
reach to uh
um cancer patients who are responding
differently to differently
so how do we go about this for example
as I already introduced you so we have
to uh analyze and we have to uh for
example
um consider data from different sources
like from different molecular sources
from different uh
um even different sample sources like
microbial composition of our bodies and
with the environment that it is actually
thriving in and how they are responsible
to dis responsible for destabilization
of the immune system and that leads to
clinical manifestation of disease
specific to the microbial abundance in
specific parts of our body and we can
also relate or integrate cellular omics
data with clinical phenotypical data
which is done at the several different
integrative levels that can be
associated with common diseases and that
can also be associated with specific and
rare genetic diseases and that can be
associated with cancer also in many
these different situations right
so
do we have promise to develop new
methodologies and new informative
approaches to data that has already been
present or do we have to resort on
generating new data but we can see from
this graph that there is an information
explosion and there is an increased
Reliance on the data due to the lowering
of costs that generate these detailed
and large data so however there is an
ever increasing of growing information
lag that complicates and the
translational approaches of this data
into practical and impactful insights at
the point of care so this is where or
this is what we call the analysis Gap
and this this is proportional or this
depends on our ability to generate new
data and our ability to process digest
and analyze the existing data to
interpret it for the benefit of the
individual patients so existing data
such as data repositories from the
cancer genome Atlas or data from ncbi
can be used to find novel approaches and
can be used to find novel biomarkers or
can we use can be used to find
biomarkers specific to specific
ethnicity and race and demographic
classifications of
very bad
so to what we actually address in this
program is to oh it went wait a second
let's
yeah so what we want to address in this
program is to close the gap by focusing
on the central issues that Define the
Precision medicine right by we will
offer you training and support and
effective tools to manage process and
analyze and also to integrate the data
so that we can make a lasting impact and
we can find a novel associations and we
can
at some day change the future of
Medicine
so our first headache or for first
challenge is to what do we do to analyze
this data in order to analyze this huge
volume of data one has to resort to the
methods or one has to
um uh address the computation complexity
of analyzing this humongous volume of
data for example
um a genomic data of a single cell can
can reach the
sizes of
tens and tens of GB if not hundreds of
GB right so what do we use to do or what
do we use to perform analysis on these
data right and
this is just one of the major challenges
that is related to for example uh omics
data analysis to accurately and to uh
effectively process large-scale data
cells that represents gigabytes
sometimes even terabytes of data so such
large quantities of data can actually
prevent many of us to gain tactical and
Hands-On understanding and Hands-On feel
for what this data represents and what
are the patterns of this data right so
let's let us
quickly have a demonstration or quickly
have a Hands-On
um
overview of various methods of analysis
for for example to help you overcome
these major limitations so this is how
this is we will do this also let's go
back yeah this is this is one of the
addition
uh this is one of the pipelines uh that
you will set up in order to understand
or in order to associate transcriptomics
data with different uh tumors subtypes
specifically considering breast cancer
in this case right you will get access
to Hands-On exercises you will get
access to the data assets that we used
for practice and these data sets are
curated so that the analysis will run
quickly and you will also get access to
where we got this data to the
publication that from where we got this
data and these data and several steps
that involves in processing based data
for example we have to pre-process this
data we have to perform the analysis by
mapping this genomics data or
transcriptomics data up to the reference
genome uh human reference zero and in
the end we have to identify variance in
our data or we have to identify
or we have to quantify the expression uh
levels of different genes in by
including appropriate analysis methods
for setting up the pipeline let's say
for transcriptomic data analysis or for
genomic set analysis so one of the
results that you will get is such as
this where we can identify genes that
are differentially expressed uh in the
deceased State compared to the normal
state or normal tissue this can also
help us identify genes and Pathways that
are enriched for example in a tumor
tissue compared to the normal tissue
that is obtained from the same patient
or in a tumor tissue and
data from normal tissue that is obtained
from healthy individuals
so we will learn about some of the
important projects and some of the data
that it collects and that
um
in the cancer genome Atlas is one of the
very important repository that has a
collection of large quantities of
several different Comics data for over
30 tumor types we will get a detailed
introduction to navigating this
repository finding important analysis
finding important data from this
repository we will download relevant
data from this repository and perform
analysis uh pertaining to Precision
medicine to yeah to understand how this
repository can be leveraged to
perform
a project in Precision medicine let's
say
on the other example or on the other
hand we will also deal with data from uh
from patient derived cell lines so these
are data that are generated from one
from Under One Roof or from a laboratory
where they consider several different
several numbers of
patient derived cell lines and
characterize these cell lines for
multiple omics data types so the
advantage of using a model system like a
cell lines data over patients data that
is observed or that is up that can be
obtained from cancer genomic Atlas is
that these patient-derived cell lines
can be
subjected to several analysis several
experimentation methods for example in
this study
these cell lines that are derived from
the breast cancer patients are actually
first characterized a different
molecular level and also study for their
responses to 90 different drugs right so
now we have data that is that
characterizes these cell lines or tumor
at multiple molecular economics level
and also we have data of their response
to several different treatment options
so from by integrating these two data we
will get how
um how we can effectively identify
specific molecular characteristics that
can be associated with the positive or a
sensitive response to a therapeutic
option or negative or resistive response
to several therapeutic options then we
can use these biomarkers and apply that
to Patient data from tcga for example to
identify or to
has stratified patients who are
most likely to respond to the treatment
options that we have identified from
this study so this example project will
also be deal dealt with in tremendous
detail in the upcoming program
so this is yeah for example uh if we
have to identify and Associate the omics
data to the clinical data this can be
done using data that we download from
the cancer genome modelers as we we have
been gone we have been going through in
this case we have an example project
project that deals with liver
hepatocellular carcinoma and how various
clinical data available on those
patients for example their risk factor
and their demographic information and
their for example
disease history in terms of hepatitis
virus and their complications can be
associated with the molecular
characteristics or molecular or mixed
data like um
mRNA expression or gene expression data
and micro RNA expression data so these
these Association and integration can be
made in in in this project and this will
also be discussed in detail
in this
in this program
so we will in addition to this look at
for example phylogenetic tree
reconstruction uh to understand the
spread of Ebola virus outbreak in for
example around 2016 and because we don't
want to focus only on the cancer we want
to explore the Precision medicine
approach to infectious disease research
where it is where this specific branch
of precision medicine is fastly
improving and are being applied to
several different
disease States so another example that
we will consider is to study SARS scope
to genome and the cell's responses as
well as we will see how metabolomics
metagenomics are microbiome data is
associated with the disease and drug
response so these are also we will
consider in this program
so for different parts we will this been
already covered by SRI gowri but we will
leverage the omics logic resources
go back again it's running or it's not
running yeah so we will leverage these
resources for example we will use
asynchronous coursework we will use the
cloud-based analytical server where you
can analyze large genomics data and we
will use for example code based
lessons where you can also practice
coding in R and Python and we will also
use several of the project examples that
uses published data or that uses data
from publicly available repositories so
to proceed further these methods let's
give give let me actually give you an
um
introduction to some of the pipelines or
some of the outputs that you can take
from the server to successfully analyze
omics data into multiple different
analysis uh analysis pipelines that is
going to give you information on the
phylogeny that is going to give you
information on the gene expression
pattern it will also give you
information on the structural and
functional aspects of the variants that
you identify from from variant calling
methods it will also give you for
example help you perform surveillance
based approaches and surveillance based
analysis on publicly available resources
for
um
for example for uh
SARS genome for a SARS scope to study
so let's with a further Ado let's go to
uh server and let me show you how you
can perform this analysis by setting up
a very simple demo pipeline for
transcriptomics data so let me reshare
my uh
sharing
okay just let me know if you can see my
screen once I set a picture it's still
working
yes can you see my screen
can you see the server
yes we are able to see okay so if you go
to the server T bio info this is a page
that you will take a look at so once you
have some credentials set up so uh this
demo pipeline can be accessed by
everybody who has a credential in server
bio info server uh
in the Big Data server so you don't have
to be a paid user to analyze uh to
perform this demo pipeline which will
give you an example or experience of
setting up this pipeline the data that
we are going to consider is a cell line
data that cell line data that I have
been talking to you about so that
analysis will come under the
transcriptomics data analysis and you
can for example to set up the pipeline
you can drop down this box
and then choose the option demo PDX
project or sorry let's go here not the
PDX position demo cell line project
so if you click this this is going to
open up into the demo pipeline
and uh yeah so we will start by starting
so this is the input files have already
been uploaded so you just have to follow
the lead of the highlighted uh sections
that this demo pipeline is offering you
and the choice of this analysis method
you will get to know as you go through
the program so first you have to do the
pre-processing
once you select these analysis options
you will get suggestions right I'm
getting now suggestions based on what
could be my future step so I want to
perform mapping onto the genome using
hisat 2 and then identify some novel
isoforms based on
my sample and their expression
should be Quantified
and when we do this I will want to
quantify the expression levels of the
isoforms and genes I have mapped onto
the genome and then I want to perform a
downstream analysis or a differential
gene expression analysis which will help
me identify or which will help me
shortlist genes that are differentially
expressed in one type of cellular or
molecular debt molecular
tissue type compared to the other
so I will end the pipeline
and then by ending the pipeline you will
get Hands-On
approach our Hands-On to several of the
output files that you can download for
example we will have
um
expression levels
of isoforms and expression levels of
genes that are at different normalized
normalization that are performed for
different normalization and as I also
mentioned you will get a statistics of
how well your first Q files or the reads
mapped onto the human reference genomes
or this will become the quality control
of your mapping and we will also get
results of our differential gene
expression analysis that we have
performed by comparing cell lines or by
comparing tissue types that are normal
like compared to the clotting load for
to perform this analysis you need to
have prior biological information about
the sample so this is how you can set up
this analysis and you can access these
output files and if you download this
ZIP file you can have access to all the
plots that differentiate gene expression
analysis the effective produces so that
you can make sense of all the data and
make sense of all the outputs that you
have obtained by performing this Amex
data analysis and downstream analysis in
the server so
I want I urge all of you to explore this
part and explore the demo demo pipeline